[Music]
and welcome to another day of chess and
psychology means already July isn't it
whoa all right so hopefully today you
are gonna have some fun looking at some
games that makes you think if you should
cancel in there or not that's something
that when I've been playing the viewers
there's a lot of questions about my
choice of castling when it comes to
chess960 so I kind of got inspired by
that so yeah generally castling is good
but we are gonna look at some different
ideas today so the first one let's look
at is Carlsen versus Longview in 2009
this is a pretty cool game I assume you
already know that they're not fit to
Castle so that's not the question but
the question is how Carlson managed to
play this game very beautifully and to
actually make that decision it's because
usually they making that decision to
Castle or not is the hard thing but we
can't all just not Castle and play some
interesting ish game so let's jump right
in alright so Carlson is white and very
normal opening very just normal stuff
some cool stuff come some cool Slav whoa
and I'm not the biggest fan of playing
d4 first move so this is not my area of
expertise but I do really enjoy it the
middle game that they got I really like
how white has more space already the
pawn structure it is really to go with
a chess philosophy so that's another
great thing to think about if you have
any comments or would like to discuss it
opening more feel free to just let me
know and we can do that too but so far
everything seems very normal black at
some point is going to be playing he's
six and to get the bishop out eventually
I assume there should be a be six
somewhere right because this pawn is
really strong and the bishop is pretty
blinded so those are the general ideas
that I've seen probably be six could be
met by before could just take whoops so
there are different ideas and have a
hello
Baljit yes so if you were wondering if
black did play this P six yes he did and
B 6 is a very interesting idea because
as we just mentioned he kind of wants to
open it up be easy it was kind of like
it's more like a Slav that then the
bishop just landed on f4 because of the
c6 part but yes and the bishop whoops
I'm still used to leeches and the bishop
also did come to a five so it's I feel
like I do feel like it was very um
everything was played pretty logically
so this is also the 11 years ago opening
so things happen updated ever since and
alright so my first question do you
think White's should take the pawn or
should do what you want to play b4 as
White's let me know which one would you
prefer and we've talked about this
before kind of keeps the keeps them the
tension but if you if you were to play
before then there could be a 5s and this
is just still an ongoing you could
technically play a three but
now even if everything gets taken it's
still interesting because the bishop is
strong but I'm not sure if Blackwood
wanted to take everything black would
just try and keep the tension so I also
do like before and taking taking the b6
pawned takes a lot of understanding to
do which Magus did have and he did play
C takes b6 so let me show you why C
takes b6 well taking what the queen is
the best option then you play a rupee
one so you are you do want to play in
the Queen side but not necessary to keep
everything closed because if everything
is closed then your two bishops are not
really doing much the simplest way to
think about it and oh
hello Joseph all right what else we got
so logically after take now it's the
bishops turn to come out somewhere so e
six very logical same for the f1 bishop
let's open it up now blacks you move do
you think it's a good idea to get the
bishop I'll play something like C 585 do
you want to move the Knights basically
black to move which one do you want to
do keep in mind black to move I know we
were looking at there's the white side
because we all want to be Magnus right
all right yeah I like that thank you
giving c5 is very pretty interesting
definitely candid move to think about I
feel like something like Bishop before
is also interesting but what Thanks you
can just play like you could just play
a3 take take
now the rook is also attacking the clean
so it feels kind of pointless and
something like Bishop a5 is a blunder so
those are the things to look out for but
and the other good thing is if the
bishop can't come to before
oops if the bishop can't come to before
then what's Bishop e7 the bishop doesn't
really serve any purpose on e7 unless
you could try to get it to f6 but then
again it's still a blind spot so that is
why it is better to just place c5 and
try to get this Bishop out in a better
place or maybe play something like
Bishop d6 to exchange the bishops all
right do you kind of make sense to me it
feels like it's following a nice pattern
g5 Knight e4 g5 doesn't make sense right
now be easy because just what if g5 take
I mean what would you do after that's so
I I'm not the biggest fan of giving free
material I like sacrifices but this is
not a sacrifice what else we got
alright so yeah c5 does make perfect
sense to me
and after c5 so as white I'm not going
to take this this is just no I ain't
gonna happen first things first let's
just look at it like a pure just being
able to just develop better let's say
you take with the night next do you have
94 coming up
another thing to think about what if you
take it to Bishop next if I could be
coming up it's you would give black way
way too many chances to develop and put
the pieces in better places so we don't
want that we just want to be able to
develop put our pieces and better places
and not let opponents gets very slippery
all right I see the idea with nice edge
five let's just go back a second 935 I I
understand that you want this Bishop but
what if just wish a wish to just kind of
keeps the bishop over here it still has
the diagonal I would just a 935 doesn't
really pose a threat especially because
eventually you do have to go back
because this night isn't doing anything
up here so but thank you for sharing
okay what else
okay so let's say III and what's the e3
c5 and now what to do with white we said
we don't want to take that right so if
you don't want to take it we still have
to be able to somehow attack it now how
sure anytime thank you for thank you for
speaking up so hard we could consider
something like Knight a for the night a
for it's definitely interesting but what
let me delete that but what would you do
if Knight a for just Queen a5 check you
kind of have to either come back with
your knight put something like before or
Queen d2 the blunder cause of your
knight over here oops
right so 94 I like the idea of might say
for don't get me wrong but I feel like
it's a little premature so you can like
prepare it better it feels a little raw
so I'd yeah I do like thank you
everybody for sharing thinking about 94
I do like that I wanted to sack the
double phone so you could feel at the
dark skirt um be easy that's an
interesting idea with g5 and the mission
of g7
but the Yerba Sherman tree so and still
wins per server purpose
it will just be looking at the d4 pawn
maybe some refunds later but it's not
worth it it's you you need to keep your
it's I mean your bishop still does have
another way to go like 56 so possible
I'm still answering be easy just FYI
okay so I like the idea at a forum I
like that
Thank You Manish for mentioning Queen d2
denied a for but there's a little
trickier way to be able to play this
Queen that to be able to play this 1984
and attack the Queen so how do you think
you could do that it is not going to -
and we already said we don't like D
takes e5 we already said we were looking
to be able to play Knight to a4 that's
an interesting idea to play Queen e4 and
95 hmm alright let's take a look what
would you do if Queen B for the first
thing that comes to mind is this Bishop
d6 because I really like I feel like
this Bishop d6 is a big idea that black
ass and if you take take Knight be
father's could be just queen c6 just
stopping at all and now possibly trying
to take that if not take your cue point
Knight d5 still could just take your
Bishop so I think clean a4 with the idea
Knight d5 is interesting but Bishop d6
kind of stops it Bishop d3 interesting
but this should be three what if
something like c4 would you have to just
play like Bishop c2 and then like Bishop
b4 um I mean it's interesting but I it
just doesn't really seem like it's that
um that's helpful
alright ok let's go back to here so I
still liked an idea NIT 4 so we could
just consider a three with the idea
night a four oh I just got something
interesting I got a comment about if if
Bishop d3 take on d4 that's definitely
pretty cool what if take take Queen take
like specially tree still Queen could go
to e5 9d 4 is coming looks very scary
for both sides to be honest because if I
cast all now this rook could become a
little worried some I guess but yeah I
think black could technically just take
here and show I'm thinking if I could
just play in 94 but that's really
there's Queen a5 this is this is the
line I was just thinking about but like
if there was a Bishop d2 that would be
pretty cool right but no that can happen
so yeah technically Bishop d3 could be
also refuted because of take not yeah I
don't see any ways to stop it
so a3 is the best one sorry
another question that was was about
Queen e4 and I talked about Bishop d6
are you talking about take take 95 Queen
sits next line because you say 97 and I
can pick it up right that's a free night
and if you are talking about 95 over
right now still can be taken so I see
our idea that's I I see that you are
thinking about checks which is pretty
cool I like it when people think about
checks makes me proud but it would be
pretty cool check if this night wasn't
here if this night was somewhere else
would be a pretty cool check you are
good
all right let's go back and now let's
look at our a3 so a tree is pretty
pretty awesome because now it's
supporting this might a four idea and we
like that because first of all gets us
face second of all it's not just about
the ninety four you want this night a
four to be able to actually attack the
pond and ideally be able to exchange
that or a lot of stuff over here
so let's say opponent plays Bishop d6
you do your knight a4 careful Queen a5
doesn't work because of p4 it take
there's just take two pretty cool huh
so careful with that Queen c7 know you
can take and exchange the nights over
here so this is actually what happened
in the game and as you can see both
Kings are on Castle black king is closer
to Gosling and white King is but the
main question right now to try and
figure out is what do you want to do it
white because if your goal is to castle
you can just play Bishop d3 and castle
but if your goal is to try and keep an
attack or like a little bit more
exciting than just Bishop de Castille
you do have an interesting move and yes
someone be easy in the chat also did say
mates checks and third scandal bills
yeah I think you meant make checks and
threats kinda moves but mates are also
good candidate moves right alright so
yeah thank you for everyone who are
participating
yep queenie for is the best one Queen f3
is also I think it's interesting but
Queen a tree Queen f3 my first question
is what would you do after Queen c2 cuz
now Queen c2 you gotta like think about
your rook do you want
do you wanna lose some pounds or you
want to just play queen do you want I
don't like this so I don't really also
see what is Queen f3 doing what is your
idea with Queen f3 because I just want
to keep it close to the king you don't
necessarily need to do that right now
you can't just give this Queen a4 check
and if 9797 now this king is not going
to cast on excellent so you can't just
play the ship t3 great so this is pretty
interesting I think I really like this
because let's like you give me two three
moves and I get my rook on c1 and this
is already pretty pretty satisfying
right I was thinking if there isn't a
bishop be any way to trick opponent into
Bishop b5 but you can't do that right
now because of Queen d5
so another line that I was thinking
about was potentially playing this
trying to play York c1 but with like
Bishop d3 maybe king up during Duke c1
something like that just some trying to
bounce ideas because if 97 if I play
like Bishop d3
what if opponent just plays Queen d6 way
$26.00 Bishop b5 so not Queen d6 but if
opponent just plays rook e8 to try and
castle well we can eat that right there
so what if okay seven to try and defend
d7 that was what I was trying to get at
and so yeah I feel I don't know if
Bishop d3 is fast enough we could try to
Castle but then he also castles and yeah
technically we do have the pawn majority
technically the game is in two sides
it's better to have bishop then the
knight but
it feels too easy right castling is to
choo-choo we need something more
exciting so that's why I was actually
thinking about potentially king b2 again
emphasis on potentially because it is
cool but you are following the idea of
c1 Bishop d3 is kind of covering your
king gap but I would much rather to have
Bishop on d3 King on etudes so that if
my kid needs to go back to f1 it can so
that's those are two some brainstorms to
keep in mind later on so in the game 97
was not played and they just played King
7 1 you just played King 7 and so now we
get our Bishop d3 so Bishop d3 the idea
is pretty clear I'm I need to develop
this Bishop I might want to cast up but
since Bo accident castle if White was to
castle next move is automatically gonna
be g5 g-force
so white is also not going to castle and
that's why this game is pretty cool
oh hello chat sweep how's it going
so yeah they were talking about king e7
and another cool King move from white so
here is a very very interesting position
because now black has a chance to try
and push a little because for example
let's say we play a 5 with black right
so let's say a 5 what do you want to do
with white the first thing you would
think about is castle right because
there are no logical checks no easy way
to threaten anything or eat anything so
probably something like castle so saw
are pretty good that you thought about
g3 and Bishop g2 then castling but the
issue is that you kind of need your
Bishop to be somewhere closer to the
center than g2 because you also wanted
to be able to
maneuver on the queenside but if a
bishop is on g2 the pawn on d5 so
imagine your Bishop is on G to your pond
upon on d5 was just kind of blocking it
so it's not the best place for the
bishop I hope that helps and all right
so let's say we let's say we think about
castling great now black gets to play
just your c8 and now you guys white you
don't really have this rooks c1 anymore
right
this doesn't work so black finish
development everything is cool now if
you were to play rook c1 take-take-take
King up rook b8 now attacking your pawn
whoa sorry
that's what's my mouse slip everything
is good and let's look at this a little
bit deeper okay just to get a better
idea of why magnets decided not to cast
though so and yes I agree with you
Bashar
we do need to Castle that's our even you
need to get a reconceive c5 whoa there
there was a I just contradicted myself
didn't I my point was that I was
thinking about canceling to get the roof
to see one but we don't necessarily have
the castle to get there to see one oh
hello kids Channel
all right so let's just look at this a
little bit more let's say you get to eat
on be fun on 85 you lose your beet soup
on let's say you play b4 taketake 97
what next if you play b5 I mean you're
like you are dirt ending a little bit if
white were to play some weird stuff
but everything is already kind of
defended I hope that kind of clears it
up you all right let me read it this way
as white in this position you cannot
make improvements you cannot advance
your position and that is the biggest
reason of why there is this huge fight
for the C file and that is why something
like King Castle doesn't necessarily
work because I work see it right so that
is why after a 5 we don't want to cast
off but we want to get the rook to see
file so what do you think we should do
that's kind of cube so that that moves
away right but I still would like to
hear it from you so the choices I'm
giving you our King e 2 and King D 2
which one would you want to play with
light let me put it out here - we got
this and we got this which one do you
want
all right so I got to king d2 so far so
I have all King d2 as whoa
all right so I have few e tools and a
lot of ditches all right I like this a
lot of different ideas let's jump in so
in the game they put magnets played King
eat you but let me tell you why not King
teach you
so King it was also interesting but the
problem is kind of like if fruits eh
still rooks T one Queen v6 white is a
little bit better but it doesn't
it's not anything super and the great
thing is that if the King is on each you
it lays a little bit of trap
so King D 2 is good but it's not the
best one because it's to me it's not as
tricky and that's why it's not good and
we see it supporting it but it also
gives chances for future checks I hope
that in my game I wouldn't be flanking
g2 and I would be able to understand
what's the difference but I can only
hope because I haven't actually gotten
that position but um yeah
King g2 is the best one let me tell you
why it works e8 you still do receive one
and now you're laying a trap
because if take take now this is what
happened in the game and it was better
for black to just play Queen b6 again
remember when the King was on D to clean
b6 was why we didn't do it okay so the
king e to is laying a trap because of
your take take take now you get d4
remember when we were cast old in the
same exact position white had to waste
the time playing King h2 right in this
position just try to imagine it if White
Castle instead of kingi - we have to
play King edge - but now that the King
is on e to the king is closer to center
closer to the Queen side that we have
this
small pawn majority so that's pretty
interesting right now we got to play b4
so let's say before there are some
choices for black well taking is none of
them cuz well this is a pens you don't
want to give three pieces right so I'm
glad to see that kinky two is making
sense to some people to some of my
people who I see the comments that is
great so alright let's say hereafter
before what should like to let me tell
you some ideas first of all you gotta be
careful because it was black you have to
be able to try and stop the queenside
while advancing something in the center
does the kingside you can't really
advance much so
okay now let's think what would black
wants to do there are no checks there no
truck bas rupees just I can just pick it
up over here so be careful not to go
under like that as black 94 interesting
new James Pratt nice if I was pretty
cool eval is nice because you are
threatening to push more in the center
where the King is right so if you get
the chance to maybe that maybe maybe big
maybe do something like this whoa you
could potentially start bringing more
stuffed where's the king so I like eat 5
but let's look at something like what if
a 5 I played King d2 rook c8 I just take
the pawn and this is a stoop and
playable for black but white is also
better so it's a it's a good fight I
let's put it that way for because the
pieces for both sides are pretty active
White has a clear idea trying to push
the pawns but at least the pawns are not
right so that's a big plus having taken
that away from white let's see what if I
five I choose to play if I choose to
take
then there's rook b8 now with B twos are
coming up so gotta be careful with that
you don't really want to give your
opponent's activity especially when
there are two rooks against the Queen
generally you don't really want to give
your opponent much to play with but this
is also yes 94 is also another
interesting idea but if you were to play
Knight e4 instead of E 5 I could simply
just take that and I do like the idea of
taking or playing d5 but even if I don't
take it I could just move the Queen away
something like Queen b3 seems possible
but I understand I Knight e4 I would
most likely take it as well another
thing that comes to mind is what if just
King King tries to run away if now
Knight c3 there could be just Queen c6
some Queen c7 threats yeah this is
pretty interesting thank you for
bringing it up nicely for however take
take and something like b5 should be
good enough because now clean e4 is
coming b6 is coming I like that's
alright
let's go back to our five that's we were
talking about so if I let's not play
clean be fine you double the rooks up
sorry
you bring the rook back you can't double
them up yet because well that's the
threats clean b7 is also a threats don't
a lot of threats let's not give free
puns like that if you bring your rook
back now the one thing to think about
could be taking but taking not the best
idea because what do you want to do with
your Queen
let's say you play a queen a4 there's
rook meet you
right you can't necessarily do this and
you can't also do that
so you have to be very careful let's say
you were go Queen a6 and next move
Knight c5 is coming so it's definitely
interesting but yes exactly thank you
the King is very uncomfortable so that
is why e 5 would give black better
fighting chances compared to King f8
that was played in the game so another
thing to think about is you see how
black ink is running away and white ink
is staying in the center that's that's
another that's another thing to think
about that black feels a scared trying
to run away with the King while white
feels more comfortable here's some
psychology for you that the King just
something about the players I'm not
saying like Carlson is like a better
player than Wang Yu but sheep in this
game he was but it's not necessarily
about the overall experience in this
specific game in this specific game in
this specific position black
psychologically felt pretty pretty under
pressure and wild white is comfortable
having the King on it too black is
running away with the King so how can
how do you interpret that right okay so
the way I interpret it interpret it okay
I can't pronounce for the life of me
we've covered that topic all along but
you get it but there are a lot of
non-native English speakers here so I
don't feel lonely but my point being
that King f8 it shows that black is
uncomfortable psychologically so wants
to just run away and that's something
that you could use in your own games
okay
let's see what happened in the game
let's say if you take on a five which
did happen in the game King g8 it's
already not very it doesn't feel that
feisty to try and just what are you
doing with your king like I I don't
understand
honestly why the king is running away I
think this King would have been very
useful in this like c7 then on g8 but I
also understand that the King 97 would
mean more checks would mean more things
to look out for while the King on g8
there would be only one like the checks
on the back rank so I kind of understand
it but I hope I never do it in my game
like this okay but we all we all agree
that black is under pressure right okay
so let's say white keeps pushing the
pawns and now the the push is stopped
but how can White's try and advance his
position even more so basically you want
to create more problems for your
opponents how whoops no I gave it away
mouse lipno right I hope you were
thinking about Queen movement there we
go I got a queen b5 and I am going to
keep my hands off of the mouse when I
ask questions from now on okay so I do
I'm I kind of like the idea of Queen B 5
because you bring in your clean closer
but the one thing that's it's kind of
hard to understand sometimes is that yes
even though your pawn on a6 is pretty
strong and it's kind of keeping these
rooks preoccupied
you can't you you don't really have a
way of advancing it so you could just
keep that pond over there and bring your
pieces to the other side of the board
too
try and announce position over there and
like poke a little bit more problems
there
Thank You summer okay so 24 is also
interesting your centralizing your clean
you could want to point B six later same
thing when I like the idea of Queen B
five Queen b6 that's pretty interesting
too so clean f4 is the best one the way
you are trying to create more problems
and let's say we chose a seven now you
bring your queen to d4 you still like
the idea of Queen b6 right but you're
also trying to test blacks patients to
see what other mistakes is gonna make
because so far black has made few
mistakes the first one being exchanging
the Queen to the rook
falling into the trap when Queen b6 was
better second one second big one was the
running away with the king so let's say
black tries to cover up with ninety
seven a little bit now can the disliked
d7 cover up well technically yeah cuz
this Queen b6 isn't happening anymore
but you can just play Bishop b5 still
attacking the night the night b8 is just
kind of already setting up for the next
game I guess Queen b6 what are you gonna
try to do take the pawn that's okay
we're gonna still go after your other
pieces you try to play Knight d7 Queen
d6 still attacking your knight now I'm
very tempted to actually give a check
over here which I'm going to try and
stop this temptation because I mean it's
pretty good but King h7 I wish there
were some more puns or something more
over here to attack but that's pretty
cool alright let's go back a little bit
so we talked about 90 d7 and someone
already talked about 94 like some
obstacle but the here is when 94 is also
available to you think about the
it's more like 94 is trying to tempt
wise into taking which is not a good
idea because take take andrew k6 and now
this guy is also following so let's
let's not do that now black is the one
trying to push and so yeah don't follow
the just 101 rules of don't give up
three pieces four palms sacrifices are
good but then they're not free there is
compensation right so 94 it's not
necessarily attacking anything directly
but if you were to make some blunders or
some fungal unders and yeah it's
attacking stuff so just don't do
blunders just play Queen b6 apple pie
that's kind of my 101 rule don't give
free stuff but that's not necessarily
they want a one drop but they teach that
someone else will teach you my 100 is to
make your opponent life miserable over
the board like don't let him do whatever
he wants like if he wants to cast I'll
stop it
he wants to check you stop it she wants
to take your pieces stop it
so yeah that's um welcome to my chest
rules I guess
alright let's go back to Carlson Huang Q
and yes after he's interesting oh no no
Harvey Sullivan that is not that I'm
saying I'm saying over the board's if he
wants to castle you stop it he wants to
push up on he you stop it stuff like
that
otherwise um those are not my advices I
actually advise against cyber bullying
it's not fun don't do it don't do it in
my name at least okay let's go back to
the chest
so Queen b6 what we want to consider is
let's say what if 'if I've because if
not if I what is black trans to 90 of
six well then what 97 98 we just saw
that 96 well Queen b6 stop that
see three sure what next so why not F 3
instead of queen bee sex I think the one
thing to consider is this night-night
could potentially go attack from the
other side which I'm not the biggest fan
of I mean this is like kind of desperate
rice this districts are tied up but it
is possible so we I think okay after is
passed after is doable is not a mistake
but Queen b6 just you see your opponent
wants to play 96 you stop it with Queen
b6 it's just to me it's that easy
hopefully I am able to explain it to
okay so what else we got we are thinking
about what to do after if I'm right so
ii 5 now there is a pretty cool move you
can see that black is really under
pressure right you can't really think of
a good move because honestly if you play
Bishop b5 it's pretty cool you want to
follow up with Bishop c6 potentially
what if Knight goes to c3 check so
that's a problem right so how can you
prepare Bishop b5 better I think that
kind of explains the move by itself
so what do you want to do it white how
can you prepare Bishop b5 better yes
Arthur you are correct
you kind of want this this idea of
Bishop getting there that is correct but
you kind of need to prepare it better
all right so Quincy says pretty
interesting right clean c63 c6 is yeah I
like Queen c6 but I think the problem is
even Queen c6 you're not going to take
on d5 because of Knight c3 and you're
also not going to take on e4 because of
your palm so Queen c6 doesn't serve the
purpose you want it to and alright so I
see King f1 by sucking f3 those are
interesting but you the one thing you
are still giving your opponent is the
chance to check so it's better to just
play King you want to avoid all checks
possible right that kind of makes sense
okay
so thank you thank you Archer yep King
e1 is the best
so after King e1 let's say Oh black is
trying to still bring this night back in
the game right
nice e3 doesn't make sense anymore cuz
well were you trying to go next the
rooks are tied up so can't touch that
some like f5 I don't really want to do
that there's so many weaknesses the King
it doesn't make sense to bring it back
right now you just talk the King to g8
to sleep so yes
Thank You Josh white should win point if
white plays carefully yep so after King
g1 black tries to play Knight g5 I
assume the ideas to simply play 96 and
hope 490 c7 try to still keep the
position tied up and I think this now
we're ready to go for Bishop b5 alright
just Bishop b5 you are simple
following up with your threat let's say
96 be careful because if you play Bishop
c6 as mentioned before there is route
k-6 and you wouldn't want to just give
up your pieces like that but if this
pawn was on a5 now that poses a nice
question right
if this pawn is on 85 and you play
Bishop c6 10 now you're winning right
this is a super cool endgame so those of
you who were thinking about and move
such as Bishop e5 Bishop c6 you are
correct just did a little bit of more
preparation that is why we to a4 yeah
and then we do a 5 and the next you want
to play Bishop c6 and just eat that and
next is p7 that can't be stopped like 98
okay still b7 now this is a super easy
endgame to win just a full piece okay
official begins upon up but that is just
super winning okay so that is your idea
you want to protect your pieces another
for those of you who have been following
me for last few months that I've been
constantly here on our twitch channel
specifically if you have seen me before
for more than just an hour you've
definitely heard me talk about don't
leave your pieces hanging like I love to
just have all of my pieces defended by
something so right now the fact that
this Bishop is protected by the Queen
makes me happy it is pawn protecting the
Queen that's just gonna be ideal first
of all if you're playing blitz game that
eliminates the chances of you blundering
so there is another little tip and if
not it's always it's generally useful to
have that connection between pieces it's
it makes them more harmonical but in
this specific situation it also brings
the trophy back on or to win back on I
don't think this was the last round to
to win the trophy but okay
so in the game black matrix c7 because
he could actually I mean if Bishop c6
happens like if he plays something else
Bishop c6 is pretty lost
so rooks c7 now you still do your Bishop
c6 and actually writes now in this
specific position black resigned because
well what else to do and let's see if
Bishop c6 work went to like a 7 now you
get Bishop e7 right I had other people
mention this before was it Arthur who
mentioned this why they go probably yeah
so Bishop e7 and now what do you want to
do this this rooks are pretty cut off
your a cylinder cos falling and even if
some check you just go up that's it
that's you don't there is not much to it
and what else can we think about that
Queen that King eats you move what was
it move 20 yeah it was the early on
decided to play King e2 instead of
Castille that was genius even though it
had the same purpose right to cast to
get the rook to see one you wanted this
trick to be on c1 and you couldn't
decide if King you to candy to your
castle after e5 King g-tube still like
even if you're a even if your game you
decide to play King you to king t2 it's
okay it's not a bad move it serves the
same purpose of getting the rooks to c1
the only issue is that it's just not
tricky enough so if you want to play
more tricky then King g2 is the better
one now after King you to you get this
cool rook c1 and the best for black is
to actually do district c8 but taking is
not the best choice Queen b6 is even
though if this was a castle now taking
on c1 is the best choice so there are
there are so many little things to think
about but yeah oh you missed opening it
was just
the Slav / London I guess because it
could be transposed to lung from playing
Bishop before earlier to sew the opening
wasn't something super the smooth kinky
- was something super so yeah I also
King D - you could think about what if
check so yeah good good thinking you're
correct you could you would be giving
your opponents more chances to poke you
and trying creates better chances for
himself so good one
Thank You Arthur alright so I actually
did have another game prepared but I as
usual I kind of went on and on about
this games we went super deep hopefully
you guys enjoyed it I if you like stuff
like this by questioning cast a link or
the normal test rules that we were
taught feel free to let me know and I
will be sure to do more like this
because I really like this kind of ideas
and I'm gonna be here for a while not so
nice from tomorrow so tuning in our
twitch and YouTube channels for next
three weeks you got me and now I'm going
to log off and hand the mic to Daario to
go over some other games with you have
fun
[Music]
you
[Music]
you